hello and welcome to this video Paulie
Paulie oh let's see him dead London
basically sc5 was my intended move after
C forward yeah it's not a bad response
to the bishop f form sodium yeah white
normally goes III c 3 md5 is an
interesting move here after that still
be five is possible or leading to very
unconventional positions but he seems to
him yeah take a moment down Queen B 6 is
the thing 93 now is the move I mean
other moves really don't do the job
Quincy one blonde is d4 and b3 I mean b3
is probably not terrible but you really
don't want to combine Bishop f4 with b3
it always leads to some weaknesses this
is an interesting choice yeah I can take
on b2 now but after night be 595 white
can force a draw which is near not
exactly what I had intended so is there
anything else that I can do to continue
this game yeah d 5 million d 5 95 96 and
it's slightly awkward
can take on deform can take here first
and see what happens
and that night position is somewhat
irritating can go night to see form I'm
not totally sure what this means if this
night is good on c4 or not
I have to be able to consciously and
some Queenie to where I would threaten
stuff now I'm not totally sure that the
fianchetto is correct here to be honest
then I hit six also was very worthy of
consideration
yeah this is an interesting try him
maybe I wanted to I thought thinking
about b5 here but this is really not a
good idea ok anyway this is not bad
anyway the knight on d5 is quite ok and
he cannot easily challenges 93 I will
take and yeah this pawn structure is
good weekend for wine at least ok some
normal moves bishop at 193 looks logical
okay it goes with the Queen damn sure
also make sense
ya can try to play form b 5v5 a 6b five
mmm then I'm not sure about this this
could also be just a weakness but I mean
after I want to do something positive
here not just stay in this position
which is possible probably it's a very
difficult also for white to find some
weakness in my position I always spotted
a weakness f7 mm that's true actually
that is true yet the bishop NH 2 and the
night on c4 they really put some
pressure on these six have to be have to
be conscious i cannot cook is six for
example which often would be quite
useful to make d5 more stable ok so if
you take sit I can take with the bishop
yeah this is okay this position is ok
for black I think I think oh that's uh
that's surprising yeah just a solid here
maybe I should have taken maybe I should
have taken it check okay I'm threatening
age six now he doesn't have a good
retreat only f3 which would okay so
basically what is he telling me him that
he will go to e4 foresee phone
94 I can take and go if five oh man is
it strategically complicated maybe the
other one I could have taken with the
bishop maybe yeah I saw that and I
thought okay Oh what's this i tries to
make a pawn sacrifice out of it is
blockading me on the light squares here
potentially these six Bishop c4 coming
okay
you can take it right
so two fonts he is given me the d6 phone
just like that it's clearly not not easy
to win here
my bishop is pretty awful wants to go to
d7 that seemed so covering this I can
still do it
doesn't feel so dangerous though sorry
for the sounds yet close the door my
washing machine going yeah it don't
think he has a great move him I can go
see for this age five I wanted to go
Bishop HH 6m but it doesn't really it's
not really necessary anymore time Barney
white forfeits on time yeah oh you just
gifted me the deep horn that was the key
thing yeah it was a maneuvering battle I
think which was roughly equal it's very
difficult to get something tangible out
of those positions I mean I like my
position I I don't really mind playing
it especially liking the 995 but White's
pieces all make some sense and it's it's
equal it's equal I think ya can do can
do many things here yeah this is a move
given by the engine that I did not see
yeah yeah I'm getting killed he's moving
ladder this is these are the engine
moves yeah I have to I'm probably losing
here yeah 95 that's a cool move it's not
not easy to find so probably have to go
b5 here and not night GF 6 this leads to
something that is very comparable to run
to the game with equal play I guess it's
rather it's relatively equal
I mean there's no switch I think to
delay that only I can make the move I
don't mind analyzing a little bit with
the opponent but it is really difficult
in the context of recording a video now
here I can take which is probably better
damages pawn structure juggle them kind
of normal ish move and yeah it's it's
tough to say maybe I should take with
the bishop I mean this is an interesting
try as well and then do this but the
issue is now c5 is coming and this is
getting getting tricky yeah yeah here
you could sacrosanct the exchange but
yeah his bishop will come there and this
is quite an amount of pressure here no
that doesn't do the job so I took here
and 25 which is strategically normal
yeah now c5 was played I was expecting
d5 of course and I was thinking this
should be roughly equal but maybe he can
really bring the bishop around and push
c5 possible that's probably better for
white no I have f5 so I'm not like with
our chances but white seems to get him
and this is also a line it's a self pin
so yeah here why this definitely okay he
went for the c5 stuff and yeah I'm
doubting that this is enough but it
might be enough for the pawn it it's
really possible but then he has to oh
this is kind of kind of normal I think
yeah this was also move what probably
has compensation your for the corn it's
it's it's at least close until after
blundering the pawn no I'm just better
he can still take take something and
then centralized let's say
and Quincy for this is still a pretty
good partner not sure the engine no
wants to play like this this this maybe
I'm picking it up but it's it's not
totally clear yeah after that he sees
probably losing even though it's still
still some job to do yeah so and the
ante for faded on time but the sea point
is doing the job yeah against those
setups like Bishop f4 C 3 and so on it's
a it's a good idea to not be too
ambitious you just have to play your
game and try to set problems and often
you will win at the end because there is
a fight coming up later in the game okay
hope you enjoyed the video thanks for
watching